but I gots camp that I think I've talked
about when I got scammed when I lived in
on Draper in La Jolla by yes I've talked
about that yeah yeah yeah but we can
talk what's the recap on I don't so I
was I was living with the five people on
right by the comedy store it was a
street called Draper and one day my
landlord he used to do yard work he was
like a nice guy I forgot his name but he
goes hey is this guy's nose Jes Weicker
Jess Weikart is a old friend of mine he
used to manage a coffee shop that I
worked at and I go yeah I know Jake he
was a old surfer guy you know local guy
yeah popular too so you know every you
know so I go oh yeah he's a friend of
Jays yes I walked out and there was a
guy an older man long hair he had no
shoes but he was a surfer he looked like
he had been at the beach super tan
because hey man you know I work for
Surfer magazine friends with Jase Walker
I go oh cool anyway what what's up
what's going on you guys do so arm you
know I was living in Mexico for about
six months you know doing by the photo
shoots and I any named my neighbor Frank
next door I parked my Porsche in the
back of his car in the alleyway Frank's
at work it got towed I have $10,000 and
a pound of weed back there in my Porsche
because I don't have any money that's
how I deal with my money
I go okay because all I need is you to
is to go to the you know gate if you can
loan me like a hundred bucks we can go
to the towing company I can get my car
out I'll give you 500 bucks and a
quarter a pot or whatever I don't smoke
but I'll take the money cool you're in
I'm in so I go to the [ __ ] Wells
Fargo I only have 150 bucks in there I
have no money
hmm I pulled it off but in my head I'm
like I got five on I'm gonna have dinner
tonight and we're driving the truck
downtown which is not anywhere near La
Jolla yeah and we're driving now in kind
of the outskirts of downtown I go what
telling company
why would they tow it out here he said I
don't know it's [ __ ] weird right he
goes oh it stopped right here my sister
lives here oh my god I need to run in
and say hi time I said do something with
my sister and I go right here so he runs
through this apartment building opens up
the gate and I'm out there for like 45
minutes
damn kind of looking out but as time
goes on let's do this ya know what I'm
gonna go clicks right I walk into the
apartment building and there's a back
gate it's completely open and now I know
he ran so get in my [ __ ] truck
and I go to the panic and what Jess why
Kurt works because he dropped his name
and I go do you know this just happening
me I'm like emotional anybody Chasez for
me that happened to me last week
II knew him that's how like he goes
through mail apparently goes to mail
he's done a bunch of people like he
finds out where - who your neighbors are
all that's weird [ __ ] he gets enough
information and he pulls this weird
[ __ ] it's an elaborate thing huh yeah
that's what you don't trust people yeah